[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
patrimoine et transition écologique
d'une pierre de coups
le bâti ancien représente plus de 10
millions de logements soit un tiers du
parc de logement en France
ce bâti historique confère à nos
paysages leur cohérence architecturale
leur identité et leur typicité il est le
reflet d'époque et de style variés
compte tenu des engagements en matière
de lutte contre le changement climatique
et des besoins d'amélioration du confort
de vie sa transition écologique est
indispensable mais elle représente un
défi particulier dans la mesure où elle
exige de parvenir à rénover cet habitat
sans porter atteinte à sa valeur
patrimoniale or les outils mis en place
par la loi climat et résilience dans le
but d'améliorer la performance
énergétique des logements se révèle
inadapté au bâtiment construit avant
1948 s'inquiète la commission de la
culture
celle-ci a demandé à Sabine Draxler de
mener une mission d'information flash
faisant suite aux travaux entamer lors
de l'examen du projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 sur la transition écologique
du patrimoine bâti si rien n'est fait 4
risques majeurs se présentent le premier
risque et la gravation de la crise du
logement lié à la vacance des logements
dans le bâti ancien du fait de
l'interdiction progressive de location
des passoires thermiques le second
risque est que les travaux de rénovation
énergétique se traduisent par la
disparition d'une partie de notre
patrimoine le troisième est logiquement
la perte de savoir-faire faute de
demande
enfin le dernier risque est un
gaspillage d'argent public imputable au
soutien financier apporté à des travaux
de rénovation inadaptés sur ce type de
bâti face à ces multiples menaces sur la
préservation du bâti ancien la
commission de la culture formule une
série de propositions permettant de
concilier les objectifs de rénovation
thermique avec ceux de la préservation
du patrimoine bâti sa recommandation
phare elle élaboration d'un diagnostic
de performance énergétique spéciale bâti
ancien
parallèlement elle encourage
l'amélioration de la certification des
professionnels car il apparaît
fondamental d'assurer la montée en
compétences des diagnostiqueurs des
accompagnateurs rénovent des bureaux
d'études des maîtres d'oeuvres et des
artisans en matière de connaissances du
bâti ancien et d'utilisation des
matériaux biosourcés
la commission de la culture invite aussi
les collectivités territoriales à la
réalisation d'inventaire du patrimoine à
protéger en matière budgétaire elle se
prononce en faveur de la réorientation
des aides financières et fiscales
destinées à soutenir les rénovations
enfin la commission encourage le
dialogue interministériel entre le
ministère de la Culture et celui de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]